there has been a lot of DLC analysis
already in forums videos and streams the
community is scrounging to find out
everything we can from this one image
and I'm here to posit some definite
answers once and for all I think there
are some relatively certain things we
can say about the DLC Beyond pure
speculation there are enough hints and
themes in the teaser image that when
taken together they only point one way
to me now the DLC could always be
completely new stuff but if it's related
to the base game in any meaningful way I
feel confident that this image is
pointing to a conclusion to the stories
of mikola and Godwin so let's see what
the DLC will be about and feel free to
subscribe to the channel if this stuff
interests you as I will be doing much
more DLC lore as we get more info with
that let's Dive In as I said there have
been lots of great videos that give a
lot of good contextual info V limit
sakiro doobie lore Hunter zeostorm and
Raph are just a few I've seen and I
highly recommend giving them a watch
yourself their ideas help set the stage
for this video mostly I think a lot of
their observations will agree with what
I conclude but one Divergence is that
Raph makes a case for the figure in the
image being a Young America plenty of
the rest of raps analysis I agree with
but here I disagree I think we can be
pretty confident that this is mikola
there are the obvious similarities in
hair and design plus the fact that mikla
is referenced as quite a feminine person
which justifies the traditionally more
feminine side saddle riding ref says
that the rider looks to be an adult so
it can't be mikola as he was cursed to
eternally be a child but as we will see
later on this whole area is likely a
dream or Spirit realm it could be
nikola's dream or a dream realm where he
has some influence especially as his
alter ego Saint Trina is heavily
associated with dreams if there this is
the case it makes sense mikola would
allow himself to be free of his curse in
his dream world and this would explain
him having the body of an adult and not
a body eternally cursed to be a child
another point for mikola over America is
that America's story feels relatively
done yes we could have a more fleshed
out origin for her but in game we do get
to hear a lot about her past actions and
we see the culmination of her story at
the game's end whereas for Mikala it is
basically a story Untold he is one of
the most prominent demigods who made
some of the biggest moves like biting
against the outer Gods yet his story and
Ambitions are extinguished by moog's
kidnapping America doesn't need a DLC
feature to be a worthwhile character but
mikolak could definitely do for more
substance and for a conclusion to his
efforts of rebellion most of the other
demigods have had some big culminating
actions the DLC is a perfect stage to
get that for mikola and Godwin and we
can see a setting for both of these
figures if we look more at the total
composition of the image another point
for mikla in my eyes is that the tone of
the image looks more like an ominous
conclusion of effort than it does a warm
start at the beginning of an
adventurer's Journey more reason against
a Young America who would have just
arrived to the lands between to start
her journey we have seen in previous
videos of mine and other lore creators
that a big thing Michelob was trying to
do was Grant Godwin a true death as
noted in part by the golden Epitaph the
DLC image Vibes with a free mikola
finally able to move forward and do
something to finish his plans involving
Godwin and the eclipse or something
along those lines now I say that the
image Vibes towards a god-wing
conclusion in large part due to the
color schemes and background the most
prominent colors in the image are gold
and black the colors of death blight a
characteristic of Godwin and his corpse
the black trees and golden sap make me
think of the death lightning incantation
and the debris around the trees Bears a
striking resemblance to deathroux as
many others have noted in my short I
talked about how the debris looked like
a was falling off from a recent
constriction of the serpentine tree it
still could be that or the effects of
deathroot or even some degree of both
death root plus debris something like
death root growing and being part of
what wraps around and attacks the
archery would be quite in line with the
talk of the gray tree we get from Death
Roots item description and these
connections definitely make the Godwin
case seem even more plausible
if we look to the landscape showcased in
the image we see something foreign to
the lands between there isn't really
anywhere in game that looks like this
with the flat Rolling Hills of the
foreground and the low mountains near
the archery in the background we don't
necessarily have to take this concept
art as showing up in the game one-to-one
but most concept art in the art books
did end up mirroring the real locations
pretty closely and a lot had a character
in The foreground overlooking the wide
area angle so it's not a stretch to
think that this is supposed to be more
like the artbook location art as opposed
to something like the Vic promotional
poster which wasn't a real place in game
if this is a real place then we'd have
another reason to think this is a dream
or Spirit realm as that could be the
reason for the altered landscape the
lore Hunter noted that it is a pretty
surreal feeling landscape and I think
that captures The Vibes well and gives
more support for a dream as dreams are
some of the most surreal experiences
with what is familiar often sandwiched
between the Absurd an aspect of the
landscape we also never see in game are
the boundless feel of wheat in their
videos vlim and lorehunter brought up
some strong connections between mikola
and the Greek goddess Demeter who is
connected with Harvest grains and
abundance and also death in the
Underworld sakiro dubi showed some
similar connections with the cut content
and mikola's abundance Twin Blade weapon
these references and the overwhelming
abundance of wheat make the candidacy of
mikola that much more sure to me
especially because they would all also
fit the case of a Dreamscape made by
mikla his dream would likely share his
attributes abundance and Grain in this
case
secure Doobie has shown a lot of the cut
content and its relation to mikola via
Saint Trina all of which helped make the
case for dream themes in the DLC so if
you're more interested in those details
check out the appropriate videos I'll be
linking all of the reference videos in
the description one more note here is
that the abundance Twin Blade has a
skill nikola's hidden blade which is
especially strong against those who live
in debt the peons of Godwin this then
pairs with the fact that the ghost
Graves emits the wheat Fields can be
found in the Altus plateau in solid form
and here they are patrolled by none
other than those who live in death the
Michela Godwin connections were already
plentiful in the base game and we can
see that they keep adding up here in the
little bit of DLC we've been teased of
course the cut content might not come
into play but it does show how a lot of
the direction before release did have
the two demigods intertwined from
another piece of that cut content secure
Adobe posits that this might be where we
start the DLC in a place that used to be
called Saint Trina's Hideaway in the
Altus Plateau given the other
connections we've just seen in Altus I'd
say this is definitely plausible and
just to put a bow on connections and
evidence towards a Godwin mikola dream
Escapade the only time so far we go into
a dream world in Elden ring is when we
fight portasex the dragon friend of
Godwin who was corrupted by his death
Essence we get to this deathbed Dream by
way of fear as she is serving Godwin
with a dream realm connected to Godwin a
cut content dream Quest connected to
mikola AKA Saint Trina and evidence in
the DLC image that points to a dream
world heavily involving both Nikola and
Godwin I think the only reasonable
conclusion that can be drawn is that the
DLC will focus on mikola and Godwin
sorry with the knowledge we have of them
so far this setting seems like will be a
continuation of their stories and likely
some form of conclusion to them whether
that be a positive or more Grim one we
might Aid Michala in bringing about the
true death of Godwin or we may even act
against him maybe he won't be able to
handle what has to be done either way
there are path to acquire his great Rune
through Assistance or combat Nikola and
Godwin are both Mighty characters of
Elden ring lore so it makes the Matic
sense that they will be featured
prominently in the DLC and it means that
they'll probably provide for some great
content in story and in gameplay a boss
fight with a prime Godwin or some
zombified fish Godwin corpse will be
pretty Grand especially if it has a
backdrop of the battling trees and
before we close we could try to say
something about the architecture found
in the image as that's the only part of
the picture I haven't talked about well
that in torrent but we'll leave him for
later I think it's pretty hard to say
much from these pieces and other videos
have already done a good job at that
there are some small details like the
coffins means something we've seen
before and a death connection but not
much else that adds or detracts too much
in either way from the main thrust of
what I think this DLC will be overall I
think that if the DLC isn't holy and
totally new stuff then most signs we've
been given point to it being about
Nikola and Godwin and doing something to
progress and or conclude their
storylines after all we have put almost
every other demigod to rest and ended
their stories so getting some closure on
these two makes sense we might not
change the ending of the game but the
themes of our journey will likely be
re-emphasized and we can still get some
character closure we may Aid mikola we
may gain a rival motive and fight
against two of the most enigmatic and
Powerful demigods a Godwin corpse boss
fight a dream version of Melania even
just seeing Nikola In the Flesh would be
big and I think this is the direction
the DLC is going with all the evidence
laid out there seems to be no argument
about the focus of this DLC the end of
the demigod stories and how such an end
affects the archery but we will have to
wait for the DLC to actually come out to
test these ideas I will surely be doing
that on release of the DLC or any
trailers or whatnot so subscribe if you
plan on keeping up with the lore
developments and let me know in the
comments when you think we might get
this DLC thanks for watching thanks to
my patrons for supporting me and see you
in the next video peace